welcome to this 15-minute game and it's
a bit late to start screwed up something
with the recording so let's see we angle
going for a Sicilian here let's say I
read that con variation no is playing be
three hmm yeah of course you can do that
after you six it's especially
interesting to play play be three as
some very often it's a good idea for
black to set up something like d65 like
a wall of pawns against the bishop but
ok after your 6 is not so attractive
anymore let's see what white is doing
now ok d 3 t3 didn't really expect that
normally why place them instead of
bishop b2c form too so that Knight c3 is
easily available with the pawn on c4
this looks a bit passive okay well maybe
it's not so bad ok i can go d5 until
i'll do that question is what is why
doing now just 92 m I thought maybe
taking would be interesting
yeah the problem is i'm having some
pressure on d5 and what is white going
to do you certainly don't want to play
e5 and kill your own bishop here okk
Queenie too okay it's probably a good
idea are now playing g3 I guess yeah
that was the idea okay if I'm castling
here let's let's start with that should
g2 i guess and the question is is it an
idea for me to take on e4 and play
Bishop to a 6 and I can even play c4
that's not really leading to much okay
completing development yeah t will
probably just cancel now the question is
then what is my plan i mean i have read
decent enough development but how to set
up the pawn structure here in general
against this bishop on be tool i would
like to play deform closing the diagonal
like d4 and d5 typical king's indian
fashion where I'm trying to claim that
b3 Bishop b2 is just not making much
sense yeah that's probably true it's not
making much sense in the structure but
b6 and Bishop PCB Bishop d7 is also
pretty useless in this type of structure
interesting
also I'm not sure after d4 if maybe
there is a five no but I have 95 ok so
I'm doing that try to close the position
now both bishops here this b6 Bishop d7
and b3 Bishop b2 is about them not
perfect
I can easily imagine that I'm playing is
65 and then Bishop see items can be can
be an ID n but ok let's see what and why
it is doing first yeah I wonder maybe
nitey one could be an alien night you
want an F for all that one very similar
idea however if I go night is seven here
on 98 98
and it will probably play night h3 young
and then have form hmm not sure I'd like
to go here to have the night on d6 later
night h3 now is pretty much the only
sensible move I guess and then I'm
playing a 5 completing the skins Indian
structure yeah f for this was to be
expected question is should i play f6
even on cannot avoid it and maybe can
avoid it actually just play 96 first
there is no serious pressure yet on e5
and I can still play f6 if you place for
example 93 now now so just f6 I guess
may I could think of taking on a forward
that does not look right really let's
let's just support the center here
yeah this probably prepares a further
g-form the question is should I now I
guess so well the bishop is really
totally useless on b7 the question is
are these are completely forgot about
hmm yeah and that's a somewhat don't
miss misstep to forget about the move
mmm yeah it's quite obvious that this is
a very valid idea exchanging the
somewhat bad bishop okay it's not fatal
or anything but I should have considered
the move okay I'm not going cool these
seven first here connecting looks he
goes f5 I have g52 to block it
completely I could also play pong g 6 cm
just covering a fire okay this looks
like a simple way to play and fire a
plane g5 technically speaking I have the
bad bishop with the pawns on dark
squares and Dwight has the good Bishop
while this is nice for wide that he
enjoys them correct bishop let's say for
the pawn structure but me having
everything on dark squares is not a big
problem really that sometimes a
misconception that it is always just
about the the color of the pawns it's
also a bit of a bit about space of
advantage and ta black has a substantial
space advantage well having this let's
say on paper bed Bishop is not really a
problem I get in c4 so so I don't really
have a problem with that with this piece
it will get active later mm yeah he's
playing this a bit slowly with King g2
went shop c1 I wonder if I should place
he for now right away no he may be can
take it twice but it looks like a very
bad bone structure I'm going for that
making sure I get this in
if it takes on c4 now hmm wonder yeah
the more than one interesting way to
play one would be Queen to e6 I guess
yeah queen is six attacking the pawn and
if you go see five I play Queen c4
that's actually quite a nice idea yeah
this looks quite good even after Bishop
a 3 hold I can still take on c4 with the
night a night on c4 would be a real
annoyance so it's not so easy to attack
it and push it away from z4 and it's
just very active always having night III
in mind and similar things yeah Quincy
form this was my idea isn't it a good
move just to text the Queen and term
Quinn c5 of course if it moves the Queen
I can consider where to take depending
on where he's going while he has really
no place to go to be honest Queen d3
maybe but well I just take c5 if it's
not a big deal at all now I think this
is good for black this double capture on
c4 wasn't a good idea
you know I think black was fine anyway
because all the queenside play is just
really clear but I don't think that this
was any good no this is just a great
piece on c4 yeah I interesting yeah i
just take with the poor that's just the
best move you cannot play Bishop g5 and
then well we can I take it 93 edwins
yeah and where are you going with this
really hmm
yeah 96 obviously but I don't really
know what happens if i go let's say look
f6 I just covering I cover just cover it
and I'm threatening something like age
six and wait 96 is really not doing much
is it I mean let's say H 696 rook f6
Luke c7 and rook a 2x6 our okay this is
not really threatening much it's not
really threatening much
hmm yeah interesting maybe just go rogue
f6 before I'm for even more behind on
the clock the other move that maybe was
interesting was Luke to be eight which
would also hamper his development very
seriously I mean in this position he
might have exactly exactly this moves
hmm I wonder Leia wait wait wait is it
an idea to play rook to be eight just
exchanging this active rook maybe but
I'd like to start with this first and
push the night back that it really looks
like a good way to play
k is the rookie on b1 threatening to to
enter my position on b7 well it's not
really a threat I can I can play em
easily I came maybe maybe look be five I
mean that is not a threat and in the
pure sense of the world would be five
but I'd like to get the pawn back easily
however there is maybe night f23 here i
would i would like to play rook a fade
really to prevent night f2 rugby fire
fists I can play a six but that I don't
like to do that okay I'll do it anyway I
would like to keep the pollen a 72 have
Bishop c5 but should be six having a
stable post for the bishop but probably
a you can't have it all okay just went
to be seven maybe in ten new group c 7
but ok now i can i can just take it
yeah he's in a bit of a pinning
situation here on them on the Kings side
I know I'm actually threatening
something night d6 takes you takes on e4
that's a big threat really which is not
really addressed I'm not sure that it
could address it but there's also the
move d3 now d 3 part takes bishop g1 but
it can take c form okay well let's just
continue here this is good anyway I
guess it's tricky to find a spot for the
rookie even I mean rook c7 looks like
hmm it could be this kind of trip
without any return to get rook c7 you
should be 6i when the night is hanging
of course yeah well my original idea was
Knight takes e4 and i think i can i can
play that or is there any drawback
rookie one maybe maybe you come on
and that's a bit of a shame nitey for
look at you one don't I have anything
good after that I'll nikon okay i can go
to c3 and if it takes on e5 there is
this check on f2 now that's probably
good for black right would be really
weird if it wasn't yeah rookie one night
see 395 probably 95 and then we'll give
to check the serm should be quite good
or is there another square no guess not
let's let's just do that a pin I meant
five not four minutes yeah maybe maybe
on rook f2a can just go to f3 it's not
it's not an instant loss I guess
by boyd woodward I can take here if he
takes with the rock this Bishop t6
winning the exchange and I can also
start with the check okay I asked that I
take your first he needs to go rook
takes and then Knight g4 maybe maybe
that's the real of the real problem
write a check first King to h3 mmm well
not quite sure is there really something
i go here first or kevin three minutes
maybe Bishop f4 here like g5 h3 hmm
okay he's trying to defend actively
brooke f talking a tree root age to
check pink eggs there is no mate really
that's a disappointment if I give the
check and then rook g6 wait i Luke g6 of
course is not not even a move checking
King edge 3h five proof rook takes age 5
has also knowing okay
look g6 threatening rook f2 maybe as no
sugar for I can probably just take I
don't see a win here which is a bit of a
shame because it really looks like there
should be one rock g6 is also Knight f3
so this is probably useless if I give
the check that some way to I don't see
it I don't see a win unfortunately I
mean HD 123 or something yeah I don't I
don't see it I really don't see you win
and I can now the night now is hanging
and this is no win Luke age to King
takes time morning yeah I do I even go
with this piece that's weird really
weird now I didn't see I didn't see you
and I mean this is quite quite
astonishing in my book because it looks
like white is totally on the ropes but
sometimes there just isn't a win even
though it looks like it looks terrible
35 seconds well that's not good
completely lock let the clock run down
now okay if you find the mate then
everything's cool but I I didn't
now a very strange also really I was
pretty confident that there should be
something but I didn't see it not at all
I mean there's this bishop everything's
misplaced but I didn't didn't find find
a knockout I'm driving for g5g for him
or h5 is this a move h5 threatening
Knight g4 in a way now will g5g five
looks better also threatens them made
there is no mate threat really that that
i have just like his is tied down in a
way Rupe defaulters look at three made
into you can always try okay and now i
need to get get the night into play or
maybe they're this first is first that's
actually a good move and here i get to
go here check yeah I've got eight
seconds What What nonsense yeah I simply
didn't didn't find didn't find the win
which was certainly there I'm very sure
about that check
you
yeah seven seconds is really too little
the position I'm not not so sure about I
mean maybe I'm active enough for draw
but obviously am impossible to to make
the moves now this would be okay even
with the very little increment I oh it's
it's so active that ya know I'm even
glad I mean theoretically speaking
winning um but ok let's just I just used
up all my time here to find the maid and
I didn't find it so let's see where the
computer shows the win what is winning
exactly here look F to check and night f
seven wins okay so look at shank shank
and now night f7 well that's not exactly
intuitive with treating the night what
is it what's the idea XO exactly the
computer plays Knight f7 and then wrote
the eight to d5 ok and while that's
tricky that's really tricky to to to see
maybe I had an even easier when earlier
we should be six years completely
winning
why exactly I because I'm just okay
that's very easy actually rooks e6 looks
e-cigs rookie for look-see two picks up
the bishop yeah this is just this is
total curtains this is piece doesn't
even have a square I mean whereas
through going it is it is strapped like
that okay so kind of a holla this is so
game was of course a very stupid play by
me but should be sick I mean not the
whole game he was he was completely
busted of course and this this is just
yes terribly bad but i just spent far
too much time on this stuff I mean every
move is just good for black so just a
matter of maximizing returns and hear ya
hear Bishop b6 is just totally winning I
just thought that here there should be a
win as well I mean that probably is with
rook f29 f7 but this is not very easy to
see and what I actually played I wasn't
clear ok this is also totally winning
Knight f6 is minus 4 okay but I must
admit that I don't understand why why is
this minus 4 let's consider and what did
I play actually they are played that
okay yeah okay there's also a question
of what else and now g5g five is also
totally winning okay i played this move
okay well as I saw azita saw this but I
wasn't sure what what exactly my
continuation should be after g4 for
example and then that CD 50 wow wow I
really should stop playing right in the
morning it like totally totaled it
idiocy why did
night we ate and TI at add 50 seconds
okay g5 also talked completely winning
okay here looks it two wins I mean every
move seems to win besides what I played
g5 also okay didn't do that g5 again is
totally winning 34 and now night XD
force is a win why exactly a [ __ ] of
course of course nergy for aa9455hm and
this is check checkmate not working okay
well this was also one here it's just
equal check check ya lo que didn't
matter because we have no increment I
mean with five seconds I was losing any
way he could play a play any move
basically and without time here of
course black is also completely winning
but he didn't pay any attention anymore
it wasn't necessary um yeah I dream just
homeless I'm just not awake it seemed
asleep it wasn't i wasn't exactly
difficult to to win many many good
opportunities the easiest probably being
I mean besides bishop be six to play g5g
I'm not really sure why i discarded that
and i cannot tell really because it's
clear that he's not meeting me I'm have
every F I have h7 covered but I simply I
simply didn't see the move I don't know
why wow that's really mean this what
about this yellow men this one
he can get this check but but what
exactly now with the rook I mean you can
go here okay and I just have this King
is much much more insecure it's it's two
pieces and to not playing they never
played in this game so yeah but okay if
you're totally blind it is not help
alright thanks for watching